contenta de estar aquí es un reto para
mí hacer otra cosa en el escenario que
no sea cantar
me voy a presentar nuevamente es el que
me presentó era parte de mi exposición
importante
puedo darme el lujo de comerme de ese
minuto de presentación bueno mi nombre
es giovanna núñez
soy músico autodidacta compongo
canto también
produzco mi música y bajo el nombre del
ala
también estudié filosofía en la
universidad antonio ruiz de montoya
hoy no quería contarles mi experiencia y
me voy
a dar un concierto sino que quería
compartir resonar quietud que tengo yo
como músico sobre cuál es la situación
de la música dentro de este contexto que
llamamos industria musical
voy a seguir leyendo
desmayarme
porque esto para mí es un poco
conflictivo
porque pienso que la música tiene
cualidades
determinadas que no necesariamente son
amigas de la cualidad de propia
industria
empiezo por preguntarme qué cosa ha sido
la música parecer humano
durante nuestra historia y qué cosa es
la música para nosotros cada uno
atomizados
pienso que la música ha sido un espacio
para poder socializar aquellas cosas que
que nos asombraba que nos aterraba que
nos importaba mucho y que eran tan
profundas
difíciles de aprender con la razón
no estaban en el día a día está
en lo ritual estaba en los momentos de
catarsis quizás un poquito de alcohol
pero la música siempre fue un espacio
para poder canalizar cosas que nos
importan y que no podemos nombrar
y quizás justo el hecho de que no
pudiéramos nombrarlas es lo que las hace
tan angustiantes a veces tan
apasionantes a veces
y
y bueno
qué es lo que caracteriza la industria
frente a esto frente a esto que nos
desborda que no podemos controlar que
encontramos en el arte en general esto
que habla de una parte de nosotros que
no está normada por las no por el orden
social por nosotros mismos las cosas que
nos superan
qué pasa cuando ponemos
la música como un producto dentro de una
maquinaria digamos de producción porque
si bien la industria musical es una
industria cultural
algunos
mandatos de una industria cualquiera por
ejemplo la idea de producir más a menor
costo la guía de producido mucho
y para el mercado un cierto entonces
qué pasa con un elemento como la música
cuando quiere encajar a las demandas de
una industria que también le pide
regularidad frecuencia cierto tipo de
producto el envase tiene que estar
bonito o sea uno
tiene que estar bueno y tienes que hacer
cosas extra musicales como tomarte fotos
para algo importante y tomarte también
unas fotos es como que hay un trabajo
alrededor de aquello delicado y
trascendente que es la música que tiene
que ver con un trabajo más de marketing
que de introspección o de comunicación
de algo trascendente de sociabilización
de algo colectivo importante no son
cosas más propias del mercado
de hecho hay muchas maneras de componer
no hay manera de componer que son más
pensando
la belleza formal de la pieza
y tengo colegas muy queridos que dicen
todo el su oficio
todo conocido se puede conseguir pero yo
pienso que la música tiene un componente
que para mí existe es imprescindible que
es el de la inspiración
y la inspiración no se puede convocar a
voluntad
no puedo decir quiero inspirarme y
escribir algo que me conmueva y que
hable de cosas que mi razón no conoce no
puedo decir eso
parece que la inspiración llegará cuando
quiere
y a veces nos hace decir cosas y hacer
cosas y pensar cosas que no
encontrábamos por lo menos dentro de
nuestro espectro racional
yo no piensa o existirá pues esa
inteligencia colectiva que uno puede
percibir y
aterrizar a través de una idea o de una
pieza de arte de repente es un espíritu
que los inspira de repente es un regalo
de dios quien cada quien tiene su
lectura de la inspiración pero para mí
es un elemento fundamental
el arte en este caso la música
haga eso que nos ha hecho durante toda
nuestra historia humana
como verles y de comunicarnos entre
nosotros desde una parte que no es
racional que es muy profunda que es
vital
quiero contarles una historia personal
además para dejar de hablar que me pone
muy nerviosa y poder cantarles algo pero
esto de esta canción viene de una
historia muy extraña bueno yo tenía 22 o
23 años y era muy agnóstica de estudio
de filosofía y además me gusta del arte
entonces quién me va a meter a mí
cristiano pues
nada
pero un día estaba caminando por el
parque que está por mi casa y de pronto
empiezo a sentir que los árboles vibraba
nunca he comido amigos pero por lo que
me cuentan era así
los árboles vibraba era como si todo
vibrar en una especie de aire de
vaselina
yo
había un espíritu en el aire
un espíritu muy fuerte de amor de
ternura y de alegría eso es lo que yo
sentí
y yo sentí con claridad que era el
espíritu de jesús y yo escuché y entendí
sin escuchar ninguna palabra que ese era
el camino del hombre
el camino de
de que después de dar la vuelta a todo
el odio y los golpes y la pelea en la
separación uno podía amar
a un hermano como un hijo con amor total
a cualquier persona eso es lo que en ese
momento vi
y le conté a mis amigos artistas me
dijeron
para empezar como sabes que era jesús te
has tomado
estás loca
y me enamoré y le hice esta canción
y salieron de mi corazón unas palabras
dije
conocía y le voy a cantar esta canción
que se llama jesús
y
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no
el sol
[Música]
tanto que tiene
a mí
[Música]
y bueno
yo ya tengo
tales
de millones
a mí no
y tal
[Música]
a
soy
con tus mejillas
as
[Música]
vamos
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias bueno después de estar
situación esquizofrénica según mis
amigos loca y vivir como que esta
experiencia de hacer una canción de amor
de amor enamorado a jesús
yo sentí hoy yo no sé cómo compongo
no sé si voy a parar la canción
pero en el tiempo sigue componiendo y es
un disco y empecé a participar de esto
que se llama la industria musical
también me hice fotos y videos
y también aprendí a componer de otras
maneras
un poco como metiéndole más cabeza pero
no
porque yo sentía que aquello que me
motivaba a componer era justamente eso
de sentir que algo
me atravesaba como un ser humano y me
unía a otras personas
bueno
e
de hecho no quisiera como decir o hacer
esto no hace esto hay muchas maneras de
componer muchas maneras de disfrutar la
música y yo soy una persona que casi no
escucha música a pesar de que hago
música porque cuando pongo no me gusta
la música de fondo cuando pongo música o
me emociona mucho y propuestas nada más
que como bailar o llorar o entonces como
siempre estoy ocupada no no puedo oír de
chupa mucho o me da igual y no me gusta
la comida que me da igual porque me
importa mucho preservar
quisiera que en las personas están bien
esa relación con el arte como un espacio
dentro del lodo
pagano sagrado en un espacio sagrado
para nosotros que nos conecte con las
cosas de las que no podemos hablar
y me daría miedo pensar que este frenesí
industrial haga que se pierda de vista
ese espíritu de la música y que
terminemos consumiendo como consumimos
todo con voracidad con velocidad sin
necesidad no porque eso no le hace bien
al planeta lo agota a nuestra mente la
gota a nuestro corazón no agota
no es necesaria
a veces en silencio es una buena música
bueno entonces solamente quería decirles
eso que creo que el arte nos nos protege
esa parte espiritual mala
que nos permite relacionarnos con bondad
y que quizás vuelan
la razón por la que no me dediqué a la
filosofía
es porque cuando yo estudiaba yo me
fascinaba no tanto con los argumentos y
el estudio de estos argumentos sino lo
que estos argumentos señalaban y no
podían explicar qué es ese misterio
grande que está detrás de las preguntas
semanas
difíciles de responder por ejemplo si
dios existe sino si es bueno cuál es la
naturaleza humana
nunca pudimos asegurar una respuesta
pero si nuestro corazón estaba conmovido
a veces emocionado casi hasta el miedo
de que cota es nuestra existencia y para
eso tenemos el arte como un lenguaje
para expresar eso tan importante y ojalá
que siempre esté para nosotros como un
lenguaje valioso
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]